so you said that in the 20th century
global power was in the hands of
government at the beginning of this
digital century it really moved to
corporations and that in the future it
would move to individuals and I've
interviewed a lot of people and they say
you're wrong and they are betting on the
companies so why are you all right and
why our individual is gonna win out
because companies cater to individuals
and we as the citizenry need to start
understanding that we have a big role in
shaping how the world will be governed
moving forward yes indeed the tug of war
right now is between governments who
lost much of their power to companies
because the internet is not built around
the nation state system around which
governments have power
the internet is transnational it's not
international and it's not national and
therefore the companies became very
powerful they shape our economy they
shape our society governments don't know
what to do right now they're reacting
and I fear that if we do not as the
citizenry which are in my opinion the
most important leg of that stool don't
take our role then you are right the
detractors or the people telling you
that businesses will prevail are right
it will happen so are you saying that
individuals will force businesses or
businesses will be forced to be
responsive or are there are there a fear
that they won't be I think they will be
look at two weeks ago a small company
called skip winning over uber and lyft
and everyone to actually get the license
for the San Francisco scooter business
and if you read why did skip one because
skip listen to the people of San
Francisco who were tired of scooters
being thrown everywhere and actually
went to the city and said we will deploy
the service
but we will respond to the people's
requirements that we organize ourselves
around a set of rules they self govern
their behavior and they won the contract
over some very powerful companies
so speaking of guidelines and
self-governance you know you've spent an
entire lifetime creating guidelines and
norms for the internet do you think
those days are over who is going to
guide who is going to control and who is
going to create those norms the rules
that govern the technology layers of the
internet are now well put in place and I
was very busy for a few years setting
those fools around the part of the
internet that makes the internet one
network the domain name system the IP
numbers all of that is in place however
as we get now into the upper layers of
the internet the issues that affect me
and you every day privacy security etc
the system to create norms for those
unfortunately is not in place so we do
have an issue we have a system of
cooperation and governance that really
needs to be created right now so that
companies governments and the citizenry
can agree how this new digital world is
going to advance so so what gives a
digital company any incentive let's say
Facebook comes to mind they would say
they have their users best interests at
heart but I think a lot of people would
disagree with that it's been very
difficult to watch how tech companies
have reacted to the citizenry's response
to their technologies and some of them
two three years ago basically dismissed
it the word that I heard in many
boardrooms is we're just the technology
platform it's not my issue if my
technology platform causes families to
go kill their girls in Pakistan it's not
my ship it's their problem
I just have a technology platform now I
think we're now entering a stage where
companies are starting to realize this
is no longer sustainable and they're
starting to see the pushback that's
coming from people users citizens
but also governments that are starting
to say this cannot be so I think there
is a immaturity that is starting to set
especially in that Silicon Valley area
where people are beginning to say we
have a role so when I speak to these
leaders I say look you could be the CEO
very successful CEO of a company but you
could also be a steward and that's the
key word you could be a steward of the
power you have to shape the lives and
the economies of billions of people
which one do you want to be well and the
answer is it's not one or the other this
is what we are missing right now so when
an adult like Brad Smith the president
of Microsoft said a few months ago we
need a new set of Geneva Conventions to
manage the security of the digital space
many of the senior leaders in the
Silicon Valley actually spoke against
his his words said what do you mean
Geneva convenient vention zwi
self-regulate but that mood is changing
and I'm starting to see many leaders say
help us out but here lies the conundrum
who's gonna help those leaders do the
right thing so what who is going to help
them it what is yours like give me
because you know I'd love to interview
you for an hour but give me your biggest
fear and your best hope for how this is
going to work out my biggest hope is
that we will become each stewards of
this new digital world that's my biggest
help because I do think often we put we
want to put the blame on others oh it's
these CEOs they're behaving this way or
these governments are not doing enough
but how about us how is each of us
actually taking the responsibility to be
a steward of the digital space we live
in I mean one of the things I've been
pushing on university presidents is we
need every engineering and science and
computer science student who's about to
write the next line of code or
design the next IOT device to actually
have in them a sense of responsibility
and stewardship to it towards what
they're building so I suggested we
create a new earth like the Hippocratic
oath so that every student entering an
engineering program takes a technocratic
oath or a wisdom of or some oath of
commitment to the rest of us that's my
best hope that we all rise because
governments and businesses will fight
over this power game but where are we
and unless we play into that that power
table I think we'll end up in a bad
place my biggest fear my biggest fear to
be very tactical today what is keeping
me up at night
is the current war between the West the
liberal world and China in the area of
artificial intelligence there is a real
war going on and for those of us who
have lived through the nuclear
nonproliferation age and saw how people
agreed to take some very dangerous
things off the table
well the Carnegie Endowment of peace
just finished a study they talked to
every country that made nuclear weapons
and asked them which new digital weapon
would you take off the table against
somebody else's schools or hospitals and
the answer from every nuclear power to
this question was nothing that's what
I'm worried about
the weaponization of the digital space
and the race to get there well it sounds
like you've got a lot of work to do and
so do the rest of us Fadi thank you so
much I really appreciate
[Applause]